The oldest division in the Muslim world is
the Sunni-Shiite split.
Downplaying its ecumenical approach towards
spreading the Islamic revolution, Tehran has
now embraced Shiite supremacy.
And Sunnis and Shiites—from Lebanon to Afghanistan,
Syria to Yemen—are nearly equal in number.
Iran has tens of thousands of foreign Shiites
under the command of the Revolutionary Guard.
Never in modern history have we seen a Muslim
state—not the pan-Arabists of yesteryear or
the ever-proselytizing Saudis—deploy such
expeditionary forces into battle.
Iranian Islamist imperialism, backed up by
the ambitions and firepower of Vladimir Putin's
Russia, now dominates the northern Middle
East.
It's only a matter of time before Tehran aims
its convulsive intentions towards the Shiites
of Bahrain and Saudi Arabia.
United Nation's conventional arms restrictions
against Iran come off in 2020; the
nuclear deal's restraints start falling in
2023.
An Iranian Islamist hegemon is rising and
the United States is just watching.
For a deeper understanding of the Iranian clerical regime's quest to dominate the Middle East,
see the link to the book "Rise of the Revisionists" in the description below.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like AEI scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.